>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE ARE JUST A FEW
FEET FROM THE DMZ WHERE THE
PRESIDENT MET WITH KIM JONG-UN
ON SUNDAY.
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES, THE
PRESIDENT KICKED OFF HIS
REELECTION CAMPAIGN WITH THE
SLOGAN KEEP AMERICA GREAT.
AMERICA HAS PROBLEMS LIKE
HOMELESSNESS AND OPIOIDS AND BIG
TECH.
WE ASKED THE PRESIDENT ABOUT ALL
OF THEM IN PART 2 OF OUR
INTERVIEW.
HERE IT IS.
GOOGLE BY SOME MEASURES IS THE
MOST POWERFUL COMPANY IN THE
WORLD.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO GET
REELECTED.
CAN YOU GET REELECTED IF GOOGLE
IS AGAINST YOU?
>> I HAVE HEARD THAT ABOUT
GOOGLE, FACEBOOK AND TWITTER.
I WANT THEM AGAINST ME.
>> Tucker: THEY DIDN'T THINK YOU
WOULD WIN?
>> WELL, THEY FOUGHT ME HARD AND
ARE FIGHTING ME HARD RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
SHUT THEM OUT AND SO DO A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WANT TO SHUT THEM
UP.
IF YOU LOOK AT TWITTER, I HAVE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ON TWITTER.
IT'S A VERY GOOD ARM FOR ME.
IT'S GREAT SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT THEY DON'T TREAT ME RIGHT.
I KNOW FOR A FACT, PEOPLE TRY TO
FOLLOW ME AND IT'S VERY HARD.
I HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE THAT SAY,
SIR, THEY MAKE IT HARD TO
FOLLOW.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS WRONG AND
POSSIBLY ILLEGAL.
A LOT OF THINGS ARE BEING LOOKED
AT.
GOOGLE IS VERY POWERFUL, BUT I
WON.
A POLL CAME OUT TODAY.
I AM AT 55.
AND YOU CAN ADD 10 TO WHATEVER
POLL I GET.
I NEVER GET GOOD PRESS.
I USED TO GET GREAT PRESS.
NOW BECAUSE OF WHAT I STAND FOR
AND REPRESENT AND NOBODY HAS HAD
93%.
I AM TALKING ABOUT STORIES THAT
SHOULD BE GOOD AND THEY MAKE
THEM BAD OR SHOULD BE GREAT AND
THEY MAKE THEM NEUTRAL.
LET I WON AND I WILL WIN AGAIN.
WHEN THEY SAY IT'S THE MOST
POWERFUL THEY MAY BE.
FACEBOOK WAS AGAINST ME.
THEY WERE ALL AGAINST ME.
TWITTER WAS AGAINST ME.
I DON'T THINK TWITTER WOULD BE
THE SAME WITHOUT WHAT I DO ON
TWITTER.
BUT THEY JUST HAVE THIS CRAZY
DISPOSITION.
THE PHILOSOPHY.
AND YET -- THE DEMOCRATS ARE
OPPOSED TOEM THIS.
TO THEM.
>> Tucker: WHAT THE TECH
COMPANIES MAY BE ILLEGAL.
IS THERE A ROLE FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> THERE COULD BE.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE DOING SOMETHING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT US TO.
PICK UP A NEWSPAPER AND READ IT
OR WATCH FOX OR SOME OTHER
NETWORK.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT US TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
FACEBOOK, TWITTER AND AMAZON.
AMAZON ALSO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT US TO TAKE
ACTION.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU GOING TO?
>> I CAN'T SAY THAT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: YOU COME TO OSAKA AND
TOKYO.
THE CITIES ARE CLEAN.
THERE IS NO GRAFFITI.
NO ONE GOING TO THE BATHROOM ON
THE STREETS.
VERY DIFFERENT FROM OUR CITIES?
>> SOME OF OUR CITIES.
>> Tucker: NEW YORK CITY, SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES THEY
HAVE A MAJOR PROBLEM WITH FILTH.
>> IT'S VERY SAD.
>> Tucker: WHY IS THAT?
>> IT'S A PHENOMENON THAT
STARTED 2 YEARS AGO.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
I AM LOOKING AT IS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WE ARE DOING OTHER THINGS AS YOU
PROBABLY NOTICED.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE WHERE POLICE
OFFICERS ARE GETTING SICK JUST
BY WALKING THE BEAT.
THEY ARE GETTING VERY SICK.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK.
THE PEOPLE LIVING THERE ARE
LIVING IN HELL.
SOME OF THEM HAVE MENTAL
PROBLEMS WHERE THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW THEY ARE LIVING THAT WAY.
PERHAPS THEY LIKE LIVING THAT
WAY.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
WE CAN'T RUIN OUR CITIES.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT WORK IN
THOSE CITIES, THEY WORK IN
OFFICE BUILDINGS.
TO GET INTO THE BUILDING THEY
HAVE TO WALK THROUGH A SCENE
THAT NO ONE WOULD HAVE BELIEVED
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS THE LIBERAL
ESTABLISHMENT.
THIS IS WHAT I AM FIGHTING.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE AFRAID
OF VOTES.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS SHOULD BE
TAKING PLACE.
BUT IT'S A TERRIBLE THING THAT
IS TAKING PLACE.
WE MAY BE -- I HAD A SITUATION
WHEN I FIRST BECAME PRESIDENT.
WE HAD CERTAIN AREAS OF
WASHINGTON, D.C. WHERE THAT WAS
STARTING TO HAPPEN.
I ENDED IT VERY QUICKLY.
YOU HAVE LEADERS OF THE WORLD
COMING INTO TO SEAT UNITED
STATES THEY CAN'T BE LOOKING AT
THAT.
-- SEE.
THEY CAN'T BE LOOKING AT
SEQUENCE -- SCENES LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
I OWN PROPERTY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT WAS SO BEAUTIFUL.
NOW AREAS THAT YOU USED TO THINK
AS VERY SPECIAL, YOU LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH SAN
FRANCISCO, IT'S OFFICIAL.
-- TERRIBLE.
WE MAY INTERCEDE AND DO
SOMETHING TO GET THAT WHOLE
THING CLEANED UP.
IT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE PEOPLE AND
DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
WE ARE NOT VERY EQUIPPED AS A
GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT KIND OF
WORK.
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE KIND OF
WORK THAT THE GOVERNMENT
PROBABLY SHOULD BE DOING.
WE NEVER HAD THIS IN OUR LIVES
BEFORE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT ONLY THOSE FEW CITIES.
AT THE SAME TIME MOST OF OUR
CITIES ARE DOING GREAT.
THESE ARE USUALLY SANCTUARY
CITIES RUN BY LIBERAL PEOPLE AND
THE STATES ARE RUN BY VERY
LIBERAL PEOPLE.
DO THESE GOVERNORS OR MAYORS, DO
THEY REALLY THINK THIS IS A
POSITIVE?
DO THEY THINK IT'S OKAY?
IT'S NOT.
IT'S DESTROYING THEIR CITY.
IT'S DESTROYING A WHOLE WAY OF
LIFE.
IT'S NOT OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT WHAT OUR COUNTRY IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE MORE OF THAT